so we take an old cellphone and we put
it up in the trees if it has solar
panels so it can last for years and it
listens to all the sounds of the forest
all the time to pick up the sound of
chainsaws and logging trucks anything
that indicates there's in danger don't
come here what keep guys mad Erica Tandy
who bad and they yeah kita I gotta
Floresta say this is my father killed my
daddy
the Portuguese she was safe they started
to book it a contest in another Floresta
okay okay a Buddhist wouldn't a my dad
he was a Zac cake massage forgotten my
dad I knew shock Kundera Peking Chia
with a path to a garage attempt a todo
mundo Z&X with a Strang the forest it
afraid
Jayamma flourished at homage for
hardness a floresta noise at una vida a
bizarre tragedy vasta sound acaba come
to do Katina Floresta carbon-fluorine
succeed as in she monitor on a fiscal is
Angela pace is behind evolution farce
problem but complete more apparent as
multiple especially Lucinda is some
assume economist a vida loca a temp
agency for me buscando mechanism wheat
or Nike or Ashkenazi also treat opposite
end kin default annoys domina
there's a posh dad would it be easier
for us to do that by focusing on a
perimeter
trophy pond Olivia primera vez vo vo j
Chico hermoso necesidades efficacy
pebble tenacity phat le vie possibly for
the omen poison Poconos Tom Curren
the Toby people are amazing example of
the people that's trying to preserve
their forests they are well organized
they're well educated are not afraid to
use different tools new technologies
they're looking for collaboration
they're not looking for help people on
the ground in these places they're the
solutions they're the ones who can
actually really fight off deforestation
but technology can play a really big
part in helping you do it more safely
and more effectively Robin to know
sistema de una tormenta Park NJ passatti
se ctrl e eva sopressata radhaji an SE
c-- dire que nós temos Omaha dizzy
facility' is not just a museum and in
order to do is be kind of precise with
this one here because the antenna is
more fragile and sensitive you want to
put the microphone on there
yeah that's good old cell phones are
available to almost anybody all the time
and these aren't trash these are
actually really really powerful little
computers they can connect to the
networks that are there they can record
the sound they can do all this great
processing the hard parts of course have
to do with making it possible to power
them and making sure they can actually
pick up sounds from a great distance but
all these are things that you can do
with pretty standard electronics so the
10-day themselves have at most 30
Rangers 30 lawyers that are able to sort
of patrol the area and took
responsibility for protecting it and yet
we're talking about an area that's huge
and that's where this ability for us to
be able to listen to parts of the forest
24/7 it really increases the efficiency
and the safety of the entire operation
for them and that's a really critical
tool given what they're up against you
know person could be able to detect the
chainsaw at a kilometer away given how
loud and how noisy now complex the sound
really is so we're actually using an
open-source machine learning tool
tensorflow
the table to detect a logging truck the
sounds of birds or animals or chainsaws
in the forest it's amazing what they can
actually find it that we cannot even
hear and I can send a real-time alert to
the Rangers to the guards to the Chiefs
so they can decide how to respond you
Systema vehicles on jakku captain de
problemas I know technically tempo Chico
hey but a fiscal is amazing maze
community agents kdz Norte mash tempo
pronóstico to that they must be most
familiar to most a possibility
[Music]
Thank You Buddha anything
[Music]
you know so no work EDG Tennessee
Florida pair preserve our key nano day
she promised villainous villainous
problem is not intended
[Music]
not the so narrative device community
tomato severe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]